the leader of North Korea just pledged
its undying support for Russia and what
he calls the sacred war that Russia is
fighting against the West yes he
literally called it sacred so Russia and
North Korea are becoming besties which
is just another example of the
recalibration that is happening in the
global order there's this growing
Rebellion against the U.S led Western
order and Russia is kind of leading the
charge here teaming up with another
Outcast North Korea to condemn the west
and say it's time to build a different
order away from the United States as
they do this they continue to frame this
all as very existential like Putin
called his fight against Ukraine sacred
recently and here's Kim echoing the same
sentiment this polarizing language makes
it clear that this tension between the
west and its enemies is heating up if
you want to better understand global
politics follow for more